oh there we are sailors could learn the
Sun the side of right oh we did not know
existed we always have always suspected
you didn't see much a special sleep
familiar with British barristers well
said that that's actually just brings me
to your hat yes well there was some
concern that i was showing favoritism
short toward birds last week so I've
decided to go back to the mammalian
species and so we now have a half cow
which is you know that is it is actually
a cow yes so uh yes so uh it was pointed
out to me that I thought I really needed
to have an egalitarian approach to my
head where I totally agree all right
absolutely so today we are drinking
something kind of special this is sautee
I have no idea out of bounces so this is
the latest craziness from dogfish head
at ale brewed with black chai tea and
juniper berries this is either going to
be really good really bad we have not
yet tried it so Ted cheers my fears
happy Friday I say thumb low that's yeah
that is that is the stuff that is
expiration well well well chosen as
always indeed much better than what i
had last night yeah net day it's got
it's got a nice yeasty flavor as well I
really I really really does yeah but
like a pumpernickel bread yeah it is
it's from this this is this would make a
hearty breakfast actually only usually
say that right on ok let's get right to
the games now today we I have a six
games actually on the list and i'll tell
you why because I the developer of X
bugs nominated X bugs to be featured and
it got a ton of votes on the apps list
yeah so so there really are two lists
and you know be careful when you're
nominating because normally wouldn't do
this but I had a chance to play
X bugs and it was honestly really fun in
a kind of visceral bug squashing way so
I thought it would be worth bringing
onto the show despite the fact that it
was nominated on the unfortunately
incorrect list exactly well we really
need to do some work to make the process
a little easier for those of you who
don't know here's how this works once
you see every Friday on our show is a
list of games that were selected from
our google moderator page there's a
moderator called the Friday review on
guesses moderator google com we link to
it several times a week in our Google+
stream and there are two categories when
you go over the left hand side you see
at the Friday review apps on the Friday
review games if you suggest something in
one of those categories and people vote
on it and it ends up in the top you know
about five or so then we're going to
take a look at it on Friday now we also
have a set of other categories that have
dates on them and those are the ones
those those are what represents the
things that we're actually reviewing on
that day so I realize it's a little
confusing but that's how it that's how
it goes we'll make it better at some
point but right now if you want to see
your app or game reviewed on the Friday
review just go to that moderator page
and nominate it in the correct column
and I will try to not delete you next
time if you get it wrong and actually
going to have site I was down about half
a bottle of red and white yesterday and
I saw that and I said oh this is
inappropriate marked it inappropriate
and I think that actually removed it
promised identity so hey sorry for that
yeah I mean it technically was
inappropriate but that wasn't the action
we really wanted to take so I know I was
being far too literal I think oh yeah
absolutely so let's go ahead and take a
look at being appropriate as the oh nice
rato don't know it's until I've got an
unlocked that's what I preview with us
for now sweet that's okay retaking it
back in the
in many ways because I completely
screwed up his engineering on the last
one it was actually kind of funny so why
don't we start with comedy and with a
head and veil is that how you say that
Aaron Vale Herondale so um Heron bells
is a game that was obviously one of the
nominated ones on our Friday reviewed it
falls into oh we need to rotate the
display on this one yeah so yeah so
first off I not really tablet-friendly
because the display forces itself into
portrait i I'm going to make the
argument that this is unnecessary I
don't think that the display has to be
portrait I think that this is a port
from a web game that probably did not
run in portrait in a browser yeah you
know it's interesting it's actually a
game that's been built using the
marmalade SDK and I'm actually used to
seeing you know really high-end games
that are built with marmalade so this is
this is an interesting thing it's
actually a game that akin to mafia wars
a lot of a lot of those kinds of games
it's a bit more complicated than mafia
wars in terms of the game mechanics
itself it's very very deep you know from
from my perspective the biggest issues I
have is that it just doesn't feel at all
like an Android native experience sure
and and I think I think that's the
biggest the biggest thing which is just
looking at this screen and if we could
bring that go back to the game screen
itself you can see that we that we
actually have things which basically
your tabs on the bottom of the screen
right and and on Android because we have
other things on the bottom of the screen
such as buttons in this case I'm on the
tablet or as even capacitive buttons on
the bottom um it's a design decision to
put a lot of button type things or tabs
on the bottom actually makes the
interface look kind of unnecessarily
busy and so it's always been a design
decision from Android to take those
place those on top and and so when
they're on the bottom like this it
really does make it look like it came
from another platform which actually
prefers us at the bottom the other thing
you'll notice that the resolution of the
artwork is kind of random
on this screen you'll see actually that
as you go through the game there are
because we get we're really looking at
everything through a magnifying glass
quite literally on this device you'll
actually see that the the graphics
actually have different levels of
artifacts from anti-aliasing and so
you'll see it really really puts the
whole thing under a pretty significant
microscope but in any case we can
actually go we actually go to playing
the game itself and we can attack and
you know it's it is what it is you know
I think there's there's a whole group
people who actually adore these kinds of
games the music is actually pretty epic
within the game I wish we could actually
let you guys hear that but if we can't
do that for copyright reasons and UT
people get mad at us but but there there
we go but you can imagine the epic music
that might back a sort of text based
game I guess I'm imagining the theme
from the Black Knight seen in monty
python's holy grail that that's that's
that's good so yes exactly exactly that
that's that's actually a fantastic one
to think about think of you can hum that
to yourself while while we look at the
rest of the game you know as far as far
as the game itself as you can see the
game you know has the sort of immediate
exit on back which is actually fine
because it really all exists in one
activity and they're all tabs but then
you've got to come back and wait well
yeah it's not it's not necessarily
trouble but i think is when you wouldn't
click fairly far in here you're on
quests and you're looking at you know
here emerges you really do feel like
you're you're pretty far immersed in the
games i have it just kick you right out
it actually does feel like there should
be some level of stacking going yeah I
have to admit I'm I I agree with you in
principle but not in practice on this
there's two problems that I see first
even though the game is a single
activity into the user it doesn't feel
like that I feel when I go to the world
map I've just hit a new activity acid I
would expect the back button now too
me back to the home absolutely and
there's even a big button called back to
home so it really should form the same
one this back to home button is just not
really needed it should be obvious to
the you know the navigation of the game
and then to yes that that's why I was
going for you know like you could argue
that when you're at the main oh yeah
when you're the main screen absolutely
but but when you're actually as soon as
you get in here and these are tabs and
now where am I well there is an argument
as to whether or not that pushing the
back key should take me back to the
previous tab or not because they are not
be letting my time is right so you know
arguably from here you could say it
should take you out it should take could
kick you out of the game that would be
an acceptable thing because you've now
switched from one tab in one back stack
one back stack level to the other so
anyway so the only other thing I noted
on this and you know this it's hard to
tell again when I went to go and buy
platinum and I hit by I ran into this
marmalade error in GL swap buffers so
this probably has to do with you know a
lack of testing perhaps on Ice Cream
Sandwich builds its you know that's
that's possible I'm not sure about
marmalade version 5 21 and what kind of
errors that happens occurs there but now
the game is kind of in a really bad
state in my only hope to actually do
anything if nothing you I can't back out
of the game anymore it's it's come for
me I can go to the home screen and I can
go and kill it off so that that's that
was the only thing i noticed i always
like to go through purchasing flows and
see how they how they look so i think
there's a lot of work that can be done
on this title no it's not it's certainly
not enough for tenes onra that's
particularly exciting because it's so
crowded with so many of these games that
have been out for so long so you know in
order to stand out what i would want to
see is a really great tablet layout like
i would love to see this game actually
go through and say what does it look
like envisioned on a tablet with that
wouldn't need higher resolution graphics
because you could actually read use the
same art on half the screen it would
look much better and you can figure out
how am i going to display there's so
much information in the game you know
when i look at this game you know on a
tablet especially what i really want to
see is there's lots of social aspects of
the game you know and i'll show you like
there's a you can actually go battle
and and this this battling can actually
could actually be like a separate panel
you know it you know within the game vs
Holm requests and you can actually
structure the unit user interface so
that you didn't have to have quite so
many buttons on the screen all the time
but you could actually have kind of more
real actions available like so I
wouldn't have to go to quests and then
always click in here like I could have
more stuff available on the screen in
different lists so I'd love to see that
I think that the problem with this
particular genre is that just by making
a web game bringing it which is great
this game is available I believe it's a
flash game available on online and
that's great but um I think what we want
to see is a really really rich mobile
experience and right now it just feels
like the game has been kind of brutally
brought over it you're right you're
right it feels like a bunch of great
pieces that were sort of like stuck in a
food chopper and reassembled Chicken
McNugget style on to you our UI and how
I like that it seems like it's like
mafia McNuggets you know exactly oh
we're like maggots oh you the art is
beautiful and like you said you know
parts of the game player deep and this
isn't really you know it's a cool genre
if you're into it so I would love to see
this developer just I take a little more
time to think about the interface on
android on android devices this is a
great handset game sort of thing that
you know i can see playing while you're
waiting for the bus and be a lot of fun
yeah but not in this current you can be
like sitting next to the guy and be like
hey dude I just leveled up awesome bingo
alright so the next the next game that I
wanted to look at on our list and the in
order here is um pool and this was kind
of interesting because it was actually a
different name when it was nominated to
the moderator which confused me but it
is from friendly monster and they've
done a beautiful job making a 3d pool
title and I want to show a couple things
about this game first of all this menu
here is is is really lovely and and you
don't really see how lovely it is
because it's very minimalist I'm a
couple things on that you can see on the
screen one is that we're actually in
blackout mode so you can see that the
keys on the bottom have gone away and
the lodging allowing you to really focus
on the game content
yeah that's beautiful the other thing
yeah and yeah you got the sliding thing
not not here yet we are but the the one
thing actually that I have a problem
with is this menu there the one thing
that i would change um is the font yes
absolutely from a design perspective
perspective you know you it just feels
very plain yeah well it feels plain and
it feels like I mean what is that Ariel
there's a robot oh I I'm not sure
because I'm not fine Keak but it it
feels like the font that you got with
the system and it doesn't feel like the
game is giving any thought also just the
sizing of it i feels a little off to me
yeah yeah I I'm okay with it like i like
i said it's kind of a distinctive style
um but you know it is definitely
something i would consider i like the
way the style has been sort of carried
throughout here like again the design is
it's really really nice like it's a very
distinct distinct design it's again a
very minimalist design which I like so
you know I I i think you know on that
you know there's definitely some issues
wanted to kind of show how the
navigation work that's the exit go back
so this game does actually have music on
the lock screen as you know that's one
of one of the things we always look at
so i wish i could actually demonstrate
that for you guys but you just have to
trust me on that one and we've got this
kind of swiping menu that's kind of cool
yeah it's right and it's nice way you
know the fate yeah the ones that are not
selected fade out like I think that's
really cool I've got this where yeah you
go to a locked thing yeah the set is
very cool yeah the way the way the way
and you can see it's actually a nice
transition effect they're actually
following the of the menu item and
actually as they fade the menu item out
there actually fading the balls white
which i think is I think it's really
beautiful as I said I I you know this
this this is not as flash use a lot of
games in terms of the fonts the
presentation but i think it's so
distinctive and unique i have a hard
time telling the mate to make even make
changes to it because it is it's kind of
cool and let's just go back i'm gonna
actually want to walk people through the
other thing that's really great about
this games actually has a
a complete tutorial and tutorial is
actually pretty rich so one of the
things it's a little bit confusing to
see it actually you actually play the
game with sort of a slingshot mode here
by tapping and then I can obviously I
didn't drag farther enough tapping there
you can actually you don't actually have
to tap on the ball that's at that's that
that's that's this is somewhat confusing
part so if I want if I want ended yeah
it was beautiful but you're clearly much
better than sat i'm so if i actually
want to make a really hard shot i can
actually tap like here and you can see
that's that's that actually is going to
do the shot okay not you see as you can
see not bad so so that's that takes a
little bits a little bit confusing and
it tries to explain that to you in the
tutorial but it definitely is one of
those things where you know it's not
it's not a mechanic that I think that I
said I think I've seen exactly before
but you know it's I don't think I'm
gonna be able to quite do this but let's
try I don't really see how lucky um yes
I intended that um that's why I said
lucky um so you can you can actually but
so it was a little bit unintuitive the
controls but once I got it I got it so
you just drag from from anywhere
basically yeah I drag it anywhere I make
sense okay and then you can add the
length of this line has two so i'll just
do what I always do in pool just just
hit it as hard as I possibly well yeah
right yeah you we are always that was
that was well done alright so pool match
I now know not to not to challenge you
on a pool especially especially when
you've got a beer in your hand like that
and all right so let's try one more I'm
gonna try actually doing is open a shot
here we'll see about how I like I don't
think we've really been able to figure
out how good or bad that physics are I
mean obviously there's some things that
mmm you'd like to be able to do in pool
in terms of them back spin and things
like that that you aren't necessarily
getting here now you see you can okay so
you can you can change the elevation of
your cue and where you're gonna hit the
ball or to get your spin okay so that
it's actually it's a beautiful interface
like I said I've never quite seen this
approach taken to pull and I like it so
yeah I can see myself playing this yeah
absolutely it so um anyways I think our
general thought is you know it really
sums up beautiful job I mean yeah I
don't know awesome game in fact honestly
at this point the only thing that I'm
kind of disturbed about is the way that
they've gone into light top mode which
is awesome mm-hmm but then they put an
extra back button yeah well I know it's
like yeah you know make up your mind
don't because it almost as if you
replicated the I would actually love to
see this actually implemented we've
gotten so far I would love to see it
actually be implemented with with an
action bar pattern like I think it could
I think it would be really really nice
to actually have just an action bar on
top have the action on top the other
things the back he doesn't quite do what
I expected to do it does something which
is good but as you can see it all it
does is is swap that title there to exit
right and i can now I can get back to
exit so that's yeah which is this which
is not what that he does like I expect
these to be approximately the same and
they're not now while you're you're
talking I'm just gonna switch us into
the mode where you can actually see
these things are touches on the on the
screen yes sometimes that screws up
games and I think that's why it wasn't
in that but I really want to show some
things here where is the cancer today
it's up the top yeah here we are show
visual feedback are you beautiful okay
great so yeah it's actually really nice
I kind of feel like they did this for us
just so for the Friday reviews that we
can you know demonstrated stuff and show
where touches are and I absolutely just
I want to call out that we now have hdmi
that can actually show the entire screen
yeah it's very yeah yeah I have never
been so excited about technology alright
alright alright so um the next game he
wanted to go into was blitz jump light
now it looks like we actually do have
someone on the hang out with us who's
that that looks like from
uh weird student n from word hero Oh
wonderful well you know maybe we should
just yeah left over to work yeah we were
a huge WordGirl fan I am I you know
we're hero is one of those games that
you know it grabs you it's got this
great competitive nature side to it and
you know and and it was really exciting
as we came on actually last week to
start talking about war hero and we said
you know we really wanted to see a
tablet view of it and it was great to
have a developer come and say all right
well I can do that and just do one and
so I'm not worried if you download word
hero today you'll actually get a
tablet-optimized view and you can
actually turn it on and off now I'm a
little sad that with the
tablet-optimized view we still have the
zoom panel available but I will point
out is if you're going to do if you're
going to leave the zoom on make it work
and this app actually works brilliantly
so if you zoom to fill screen you
actually end up getting the car riginal
non tablet view which is actually and it
doesn't crash like a lot of games will
so that's actually that's really really
nice so so I would rather see it not
there there is a setting in the menu to
go to settings and actually change that
and so rather than I'd rather see this
still targeting at least SDK level 11 it
does actually use the menu key though
right right so so yeah this is it is a
it's not a button of shame it's a button
of does what's supposed to exactly
that's fine and I I may want to think
about other ways to do it but yeah I
mean I'd loved I'd love to see this game
actually you know take advantage of the
action bar pattern I think that
especially since this is you know this
is a game that really feels very very
native like I think it makes a lot of
sense to use that pattern that's uh you
know and especially since there are some
great there's some great software out
there that's been written by the guys
over at actionbarsherlock that make it
really really easy to implement that
pattern across different platforms that
being said you know I think that if
you're if you're not implement this
pattern this is the way to do it I mean
this is absolutely big runs and 88 runs
and really nice kind of ways you can
actually really see when we wouldn't
play one round here and we should also
know while you're geeking out about that
so is is Richard able to speak with us
oh awesome Richard there you are yeah
yes so Rachel look let's put Richard up
on the split screen even though he
doesn't have a webcam because that's
sort of an awesome picture I I want to
see what that picture is but if you guys
make sheets on the idea webcam working
who says it's broadcasting but yes hmm
well it may just be the Googleplex will
but I didn't apply to monitor filter and
decided decided that your final pretty
final speaker more far more appropriate
yeah that's specific Axl excellent all
right ray right now look at all the
typos idols up yeah
but the interface is very straight very
straight 40 you know I you just need to
drag nor do I go to your library's words
and it's sort of a it's sort of a boggle
but not I mean we looked at a game like
this last year a couple weeks ago right
this turns out to just be a much better
implementation I think yeah I decide
this absolutely i mean i think well
what's really great is that you're
actually also competing you can see with
this tablet view it's great you can
actually the words that i found on one
side of here if we actually go back to
the view you can see the words that i
found on one side and you can actually
see the game board on the other side and
then once the game ends it ends you know
for almost everyone you can see if
there's a counter a clock down countdown
clock on the left hand side so it's
actually a really really nice tablet
feel here and you can see also the ad
actually fits into a nice place as well
so yeah it's really really well done and
and i can see that i also got you pegged
uh well the anybody assumption is if you
play this game a lot that you probably
need a date out wow that i think i think
that's what this part is that that's
what this targeting means but i'm not
sure so Richard what can you tell us
about word hero this games been absent
for a hot August of last year iteration
28 of the game nice just don't know the
Android sorry obviously this concern is
erations as well it's been a continuous
working for aggressive animal features
improving you I just you know make it a
read great game there's just a lot of
fun to play
a mr. Schmidt continues sort of if you
look at the map of users as a failure
being promoted some definite pick up we
just hoping for local people must be
because the lots of games evil is more
fun yeah absolutely well there's
certainly a lot of really competitive
players out there hi I can say that even
when I'm actually focusing on playing
the game there are people who always
manage to find pretty impressive words
so I you know you've definitely got some
devoted hardcore fans out there and but
this game I mean as soon as I played it
like it was really really clear that
this game which just lots and lots of
fun and that i could get hopelessly
sucked into it for hours so
congratulations there i think it's a
game that really makes very good use of
android in terms in terms of as a game
view the one thing i would say on on the
tablet it may make sense to make some of
the thoughts a little bit larger because
you know one of the things that's it's
in about tablets is it this tablet is an
mdpi device right and so you're getting
mdpi size fonts ram which is great
because you get a lot of space on it but
you know when you're seeing the words
they found they are a little bit small
and Rachel can you switch to the full
screen view so I think that you'll be
able to see on our glorious 720p display
Thank You Polly hopefully we may
actually be able to read those words and
if you can my work here is done yeah but
upon a technically yeah we've been in or
two and yeah as we said earlier Venice
you suck less every week I think this is
this is this is really impressive I i
think the the font size on it so if you
look at yeah the font size over here on
the on a gameplay screen you see there's
letters and there's these little numbers
in the corner that the font that you're
using phone numbers is about what I
would want to see over on the right on
the words yeah so it just means on the
tablet you should i when you did when
you detect a large screen like that it
makes sense to bump the font size a
little bit
think on those as well but just because
of me especially there's also just an
enormous amount of white space here and
you know that's really the only other
thing is that you know it'd be cool to
figure out ways of me there's a ton of
white space because you know we suck it
getting words right well that's true
we're good at this game and actually if
I'd like if I if I could get some words
that were like you know 50 characters
long oh actually the biggest word you
can get is actually I guess you know 24
carries over sorry 20 characters long
but wait I'm Brian brain-dead 16
characters are on but any case you know
had really really long long words you
know then they would still obviously be
like this you can see that those words
actually fit into this little column on
the left hand side so that's just so
that just means the font can be larger
the white space you know white space can
be a little argue but also people do
want to see the number boards it'd be
very cool to actually be able to do
something like actually zoom in and out
like actually peanut like hey you know
I'd like to see the list a little larger
or smaller is is if I'm trying to just
go quickly and figure out what's worse
or it might be fun to make can may have
play with that but you don't want to say
that list kicked ass that was that's so
cool because yeah not only did I show
you what words the other people found
but actually the pattern it really gets
that sort of competitive thing I'm
yelling I think so Richard you brought
out a tablet version of this quite
quickly I think I what can you tell us
about that laying down for that you said
you'd like to see a type of version so i
put about 30 hours in year 7 sunday
formats
the sunday night comes at an illusion
that i'm pretty sure by one day's going
to write for the now Richards coming
through very quiet because I one of the
things we need to solve is our echoing
problem in here with the we need some of
those earpieces you know as like ah yes
I'm being told that Richard is very
quiet okay so Richard just said he had
some issues with the font sizes but
again no no I just he said he something
said that he was motivated last week
prior comment about wanting a see a
tablet version and wanting to see the
font size is larger he was right ready
to do that which is great I know
honestly guys you give a lot you've give
a lot to be proud of this game this game
is awesome and you've got build a great
community around it and I you know I'd
love to see this game get featured
that's that so absolutely yeah we love
the game Richard um I think we're gonna
we're gonna move on now because your
game is awesome and we need to talk
about games of sophomore yeah I'm sorry
your game just too good for us to spend
too much time on thanks for joining us
Richard alright so um let's go none of
these games suck yeah so let's go let's
go to to blitz jump right now let's jump
is I I do love the artwork it's a little
confusing at first it seems to have some
some real issues up here in the corner I
don't have any ideas on that down I do I
actually I think that the issue is it's
just not really really happy at this
aspect ratio it actually is doing better
now that we have our displaying it an
HDMI if you acted because it actually
helps the aspect ratio you get a little
closer I'm saying so if I were to go to
crop mode for instance on this which we
didn't do before because we wanted to
show off buttons of shame yes but now I
go back to blitz mood so and so now it's
cropping off the system bar hmm um and
that is yeah it's actually worse yeah
that's that's why it so it's just I
think there's just issues with aspect
ratios and we're then how that shows up
how the ad shows up but that was my my
initial take on that
but let's go back to the game itself so
well you know blitz jump is in the
jumping fat family of games you know the
author's describes as being akin to you
know things like mega jump I think it's
actually more akin to doodle jump as far
as other games are concerned and you
know it in place it plays pretty well
I'm not sure what it's a little bit
unconvincing did when he lands on
something he doesn't actually land there
yeah hard to tell whether that's an
issue with the game or if it's just that
he's doing the math on the wrong aspect
ratio maybe I was trying to figure that
out as I was playing it you can see he
fans about about 20 or 30 pixels above
something which also makes him a little
annoying to play at times also i was i
was a little home already we just pulled
our hdmi cable so fortunately i Rea
token to switch back to the view and
show us instead of the game but with the
game is back on hopefully we'll get that
display back you can see they get a
little bit more of the gameplay and but
that would but Ian did just get our
personal best oh nice so I guess my take
on this game I just don't want to spend
much time on it it's a great game for
like a school project or you know like a
starter game I'm really impressed you
know the hand Ron stuff is cute it's
nice but there's just a lot of polish it
needs to be done before it's really
ready day ago I think yeah that was sort
of sort of my feeling was you know if
you're going to to take a game which is
already in a very well-established John
roof games we've got to figure out what
you're what you're bringing that's
that's really new and innovative and
exciting to that genre and and and you
know this game this game is fun and but
I i think that the competition is pretty
extreme for this kind of that's really
the problem isn't it you know we see
some games where it's exactly like some
other game and it's just why would you
play this game instead of one of the
other games that's already been done
yeah exactly and there's so many really
really great games and there's on in the
tilt to play genre you know we just saw
a few weeks ago Cordy sky show
up on on google play and you talk about
taking us it actually adds a whole bunch
of really cool platforming elements to
know and that's done by you know
spectacular development teams though so
it's hard for me to go and say you know
this is you know going to pend a whole
bunch more work on this my fault would
be if this is a good start you've shown
that you know how to put together games
um try to try to come up with some
innovative twists on it you know you
know go go go do something different you
know and that would be my feeling is
that you've proven you can code the game
and now let's let's let's see let's see
what you can do it you can bring either
to this genre or to another one yep
absolutely all right let's move on so I
think the next thing we want to look at
is a go ban droid right yeah and I am
NOT are you a go player you know it's
funny I I am but I'm not an amazing go
play i'm not a professional go player
but my wife and on it I both have
fathers who were nationally rated um
well you know my dad just thought he was
national her dad was actually naturally
rated in China I see well in China to
that probably means something I think so
yeah yeah but of course my dad i
graduated from Cal Tech and became an
electrical engineer and a huge huge nerd
mmm I you know obviously didn't get
passed down or anything of course not
and if you're a huge huge nerd of course
your games going to be go right course
especially if you are part of the open
software movement and you you know got
pocket protector and all these things
they are they just kind of coming
together in this light storm and this is
free software but i do want to point out
that unlike everything that i have been
led to believe about go players the
author of this game who goes by mr.
Liddy mm-hmm if you look at his goat
google+ page I don't even know what he
looks like except that he has massive
massive dreads the man has he has cousin
it dreads well in fact that well that's
the reason we don't know what he looks
like it I'm really not sure if it is a
picture of his back for his front on
well I'll all we know is that it is it
it was taken in the land of awesome
which is not where he's from he's
actually from Germany well he's in
Germany but I assume
he's a citizen of Awesome bill that's
possible yeah I'll accept that that
postulation so anyways one of the things
that's nice but Gove android is it khob
android actually uses it's actually real
android UI and in a lot of ways and it
even looks pretty good on a tablet so
let's take a quick look at the UI now
this is a pattern we usually say don't
use on a tablet it is this is the
dashboard pattern and we if you look if
you went to Google i/o two years ago we
were like this is what all Android
applications should look like and we
didn't run and we were wrong we because
we didn't anticipate tablets honestly
when we were designing those guidelines
we were thinking about phones and when
he came to tablets all of a sudden you
end up these with often little tiny tiny
icons on an enormous enormous screen so
that's not a problem here website
address because but because he has very
very large icons and and it's very very
simple and straightforward all of the
presentation is here it actually works
pretty well I mean I would like to see
this via to panel display because it
still feels like there's a lot of screen
real estate that could be taken up with
something that's a little bit more
direct the same time it is completely
self explanatory absolutely as long as
you you know speak whatever language
well life is like you know there is
there's a page of links and there's a
race you know like there's other stuff
you could put us in it to a second panel
yeah which would which I think would be
nice so that that's that's one thought
but it what's beautiful also is that you
know this is using you know very very
straightforward Android ways to draw
background it just makes the whole
experience feel really connected like
this very simple wood background i feel
it i thought oh yes i am and go bad
right well it still has a great android
look and feel it looks like an ICS app
and you see it actually is a least a
honeycomb at because we don't see the
buttons shame in within the toolbar yeah
then we're also seeing the other look
and feel of ICS so this is a lot of time
thinking about the user interface yeah i
know and this is not you know with with
with a team of professional designers
this is what one person you know who
really brought he probably uses Emacs
which is like destroy user interface
design
I'm not gonna comment on dad wait anyway
you know you know right wouldn't you say
that you know just immediately we are
going to get a bunch of dislikes on
YouTube right there that is absolutely
sure so too and that's how we know
exactly Nick we are ok but so let's take
a look at that's the game itself now one
of the really interesting things about
this game so it didn't ship with AI but
if you download the new go you AI
partner you can you can install it and
it will play with you so it which is
pretty is so unix right like yeah let's
modularize the whole thing absolutely I
I know is there is there is that you
know you almost want a kind of robot API
so you can design your own go robots
basically now I'm gonna switch this to a
nine by nine board too so it's a little
easier to see mm-hm um but no it also
matches my go abilities so I think that
actually that actually works what not
look how beautiful these stones are now
they are all the same I like I could
really go for a set of stones with a
little bit of graphical variation and it
would be fun yeah but hey look a that's
equivalent Goa they got that they you
know the slate and the shell texture is
really beautifully all this stuff is
just gorgeous I know right rato rato is
pointing out that that something you
know I said have stones is something
that we could use but I actually think
just by wearing this hat I have proven
that I have something i'm not sure what
but we've got a pair of big brass
androids don't mess with it that's right
raster refresh perfect like what are you
doing in your rato this room is for
closers oh man okay ah so uh let's see
where were we so the only thing about
this is we've got a bunch of blank space
over here on the on the right hand side
right so you've got comments i guess
that's so you can chat yes it's ed
believe it's a chap of course our
opponents an AI so it might be
interesting to see so I was a little bit
of different
actually love to see what the AI is
doing like honestly that's that's where
the nerd side if he comes in my mind I
would love to see some visualization of
what of the UI I mean that's like I mean
this is yo the go is is is is a pretty
geeky game but I'll tell you that's
where I would geek out I would love to
watch a visualization of the UI of the
AI hear ya as you can see though you
also as use as you actually are on the
board that is used space so that's
actually gonna work well for a smaller
device is it completely unnecessary on
this size of the tablet I think but it's
a great tablet experience like and this
is using the action bar you know like I
just makes me happy to see all of this
work the employes placed in this I mean
I yeah I honestly would love to see this
game get in front of again in front of
more people you know there's a lot of
people out there who do love go well no
so let's visit the action bar just a
little bit just because it's such a
great app let's talk about what might be
wrong so this is a standard action bar
but I think if Roman Nurik we're here he
would say Bravo for putting your actions
on the right-hand side I not absolutely
sure that you needed to have the
captions thanks to the actions I think
actually those icons are very well done
in someone's self explanatory but over
on the left hand side now that's
supposed to be navigation I mean and
instead you're using it for status and
we've got this icon here which should be
what we call an UP button which is the
biggest misnomer in in Android history
and it does actually take you up let's
be very very clear but it but it first
asks you if you want to quit right why
it's taking you up and that would be you
know it is trying to avoid the data loss
scenario so I actually I would accept
that because if you guys otherwise it
just takes you back if you're not in
game so um okay all right I think I'll
give you that but here's what I think
I'd rather had it first off there ought
to be a little arrow point over there is
yeah so for my 4 door that where the
game starts now the real thing though is
what the better thing to have done would
be to actually let you go to the main
menu and have it say hey there's a game
in progress big yo that's not exactly
why why should I lose progress just to
go back and do you know what
is gonna do maybe I wanted to look at
the credits yeah or you know they're
there are preferences now me obviously
some of these may actually be things
that you know you want you may not be
able to change during the middle of the
games i understand that right but this
feels like one of those things that was
sort of done for the engineers
convenience it's not the best float for
the player you can actually hear the
stones if you turn the sound down I
actually hadn't noticed yeah yeah you
know that's a big for actually my so my
dad made his own go board mm-hmm and he
was telling me actually the real go
board they they are like you know 8 to
12 inches deep or something like that
and they actually have a hollowed-out
middle that's done to acoustically
enhance the click of the stones on the
board now can you actually so it's gonna
make a different sound then depending on
where you put the stone down on the
board if it's a visit well it might in
my teeth that might be the case where it
may be that that's really the crap did
it is to me is to make us really make it
tonight that's fascinating in any case
on you know there's so there's a couple
of little things we could quibble with
and that's definitely one of them I
actually don't mind that having the
titles there if there is space you know
on this tablet version there certainly
is I think it just makes it a little
clearer and overall you know I think
it's a really nice use of the action bar
i'm sure that Roman would would you know
have potential things about ordering um
I would say though that that and I don't
think it's even a problem to put the
status up in the in the action bar I
think that's actually reasonable
reasonable use of that space you know
that's there is this kind of extra area
here I'd be curious to see what it looks
like on a phone I didn't try it did we
try a rotate into the portrait is that
do anything that is a good well we have
hdmi in so I'm I suspected always hey
messes things up right yeah coop kid why
don't we take it AMI out and let's just
just just I actually did not try that so
no no it doesn't look like
going to do that for us I was just
curious you know it's again it's
switched into I think it switched in the
landscape I started so but i always i
use tablets in landscape to be honest
almost always when i'm in it by using
android tablet so that's true okay but
you know nice job yeah I I really um I I
don't know how the author is going to
feel about you know if we ask him to fix
a few things but i would love to
nominate history I mean he's fixing new
things every week I mean honestly other
there's an update between last week and
this week and you know I you know it any
and if you look at his timetable it
keeps the blog what he's doing theirs I
believe the whole games open source too
so yeah yeah which is great so I mean I
think as an example people you know I'd
love to see this as a shining example of
hey here's something you guys can go to
for implementation of action bar and how
one did have someone did a game board
and I think I think it's fantastic that
he's doing that so so Bravo and let's we
have we actually have one more game we
do have a sixth game and of its might be
in my list here maybe hexbug here we are
right we invited the developer but his
name was X bug last name x bug was it
really yes no way to evade the Google
real name filter is there pal ah alright
so next Bunch throws this into portrait
mode right away yeah a nameless one
thing you may not feel to notice but the
game is izle is pretty pixelated on this
device you know it's the point where it
looks a little blurry I would like to
see a higher res graphic set you know
for these high res devices because we
are we are actually we are getting to
the point where it's just it's starting
to push the olive pits starting to be
noticeably blurry yeah it's it's tough
it's yeah this is high I'm tempted to
give it a pass but no and hopefully on
your 720p screen if you can see this hmm
I realize now as you can see we've
rotated it so the the YouTube screen is
not going to be exactly what we're
seeing here yeah but just right over
here for instance there's some very
noticeable aliasing around the edges of
the
corners yeah and mostly it's mostly to
me and to my eye it's actually the the
text the text story survival child exit
when when I see texted is that is that
anti aliased and blurry that actually I
find it actually be kind of a little bit
of I straining to look at yeah yeah I
killed my honey my eyes are trying to
try to piss on it can't you want to wipe
the gasolina is great permanently
unfocused so that's not that's when you
get to that level you know that's that's
when you know you need to actually go
for the higher higher rest house at or
you be honest what you could do in this
case is actually embed a font and use
that for the text and and place it and I
think if that was done it would the
graphics would still be a little blurry
but it would help them so i think
there's def there's several options on
how to tackle that but i think low res
text is worse than low res art and kind
of as a general oh that's absolutely
true but in terms of what the featuring
board is looking for yeah lo-res
anything is yeah that is a death
sentence yeah it is it is definitely a
little bit of a you know it's definitely
an issue so again this is not something
that's going to look terrible on a phone
mm-hmm um it'll be great it's a great
app we're not going out saying that it's
bad it's just that we know that when we
nominate something for featuring um that
they're getting tested on a tablet and
if it doesn't look crisp and clear yeah
there we kicked out exactly so you know
definitely you know I think that having
a higher res art set is going to look
really great on phones that are like
xhdpi things like Galaxy Nexus are going
to take advantage of them and it really
really helps a tablet story as well and
you can actually use multi APK you can
actually have an APK that has higher res
art as well as a knife APK it has lower
res art and that way you don't have to
make the download size huge for everyone
but you can actually you know just put
up two different ones in peril ones for
larger screens and one for smaller
screens even if you want to do that and
again now if you do larger screens and
smaller screens you don't get to take
advantage of it i'm in Galaxy Nexus but
you know what it probably looks okay in
Galaxy Nexus mm-hmm that's not the end
of the world now I don't want to spend
the entire day talking about the the
title screen here but let's just also
point out that on the title screen there
are a set of share buttons mm-hmm so we
love share buttons we think that sharing
is great
but can we just point out that if you
use the standard shearing action in the
standard Android share button then you
don't have to anticipate whether your
user is a Facebook user or a Twitter
user or a flickr user yeah the theater
they're different button actions but
also I think they're in the real thing
about this the screen is it I actually
looked at the screen and I wasn't sure
what was clickable and what was not like
all those buttons at the bottom as far
as I'm concerned it could be they could
be badges like we support youtube and we
scored open fain and we support Twitter
and Facebook like I didn't even realize
they were actually I did about that oh
you you kind of right yeah this is they
don't NASCAR logos they don't really pop
you know and I end so that you know I
like the fact that they they they are
you know fitting the art art style but
also i suspend that you know that having
a pop just a little bit more might
actually help and also making it so that
they were that they actually did
something when you press them like and
and these are also also all activating
on on down click on android in general
we want to see a full click action
before you before we do a any kind of
act action based upon a click or like
and that's so you cannot you can
actually if i if i accidentally click
you know in between I can move my hand
over to the one that I click and then
release you know that kind of thing so
that's so usually on on it's usually on
down and then up so you'd expect that I
could go like here and and and that
would do nothing and I could click here
and then get off of it and I would be
given the option so those are just
things to think about when your device
designing any kind of Android UI alright
so some things to think about there dan
went to show us how this game is played
sure so this this game is in the bug
squashing genre which I didn't even
realize was a genre but it actually is
there I noticed you have three starred
the first five levels yes and I what I
really like about this game is is it's
really got a great sense of whimsy and
fun these you're actually squashing not
not real bugs but mutant bugs and the
mutant bugs all that good because real
bugs have feelings exactly and and all
these mutant bugs are you know how to
get you you know they're created in the
laboratory the game has a very very nice
feel now one thing it does not have
support for his multi-touch you figure
that out very quickly
because if you touch the screen more
than once you'll see that we only we
don't act we don't actually squash
multiple but and I think that really is
our top ask for a feature on here is I
think multi-touch would be a really fun
addition to this yeah absolutely uh well
you know it's I understand almost touch
makes it unfair for people who don't
have it but I think that um that's all
it probably wyd why did I buy a device
with multi-touch exactly something that
I could stick it to mine on multitude
that's right but I think what I would do
wow it's getting really hard um what I
think I would do is if the user does
really press down to touches at once it
might make sense to actually say hey
dude only one finger at a time or
something like that especially the first
time they do it to make it really really
clear that you know that that you only
have one figure now you also have
weapons so you see that I can actually
buy different weapons i can actually go
and get a a swatter so i'm going to do
that add that to my collection here and
then i'm going to start the game so this
should help because there was five
billion flies there and the other thing
i like about this in terms of in terms
of what it brings the genre is it
actually the farther down you smash the
bugs the the better Chris flyswatters
crap it doesn't help you at all the fly
swatter gets ladybug nobody does that
their armored at San Michele that's
totally true what should I just water on
the floor is salt do i'm totally cured I
assume there's snails in the game me
that there were snails the game editor
you guys exactly what it does I'm sure
that I have to use it on the snails to
keep them from exploiting this otherwise
you just tap the snails they explode but
maybe if I use salt on them they'll
shrivel up else travel app and it's
little oh that is good point I didn't
these are mutant nails but don't ya
don't bring a swatter to a ladybug fight
it yeah there's you swatter yeah Oh
wasted oh come back ah it's really
really hard um so um miss make that
really clear especially you know it the
top of that you know what's going to
happen is rich Hyndman is gonna beat
this welker next we wish we should
actually send this game too rich and say
we could actually we should rescue on
under debris yeah rich rich beat gunman
Clive which is one of the hardest games
we've reviewed in
right and yeah so the review board's
opinion of gunman Clive was wow this
game is awesome but it needs to be
easier yeah you know and then of course
the developer came back and said screw
you guys right yeah pretty much and then
and then what and then one of our
developer advocates rich Hyndman
actually wouldn't beat the game just to
write us up so apparently we were wrong
and are we meeting the board and numb me
sad because not only is he an awesome
gamer but he lives in London it's like
he's everything over it's true actually
and he speaks with the fantastic accent
as well do not start yes I'm warning you
of course oh sorry it goes to coach the
cow god oh god so I'm in any case in all
seriousness though I'm I think we really
like the game I think it's really
innovative I think it brings a lot to
the genre that's how the buttons are
shame it does have the buttons of shame
and we'll really start if you do zoom to
fit screen which is better than crashing
right it's basically its activities
getting restarted its handling the
activity getting restarted that's great
and actually the funny thing is when you
zoom to fit screen you can't actually
tell the difference yeah looks a little
bit no glory you're right it looks like
if I because they've got there but their
hard work is so low rest of the game
with that when you stretch it when you
zoom to fill screen it actually if you
could just it's just thing here is
tiniest bit blurry which shows that that
these these graphics are not even
they're not even hdpi their MVP I
graphics their life these are you know
these are graphics that were designed
for phones like the g one well and that
can be tough too because right this is
an MDI mdpi device it's just a also an
extra large screen that's also true so
that Miss so if this if this game
actually has and I have no idea how it
with programs I haven't looked into a
pity this game actually has hdpi
resources it's possible that it's not
making use of them so right was
programmed with the framework they're
actually gonna have to put in some code
to say hey we really met was not a hdpi
what we really meant is large screen
right and and that's and that's you know
you know and that can be simple as
putting in the wrong folder so I haven't
actually taken a look to see what they
did but that's possible it is possible
that these are there actually are higher
res resources that we're not seeing yep
so but in any case it's fairly easy to
make those changes yep uh so I think our
verdict on xbox
is this is a good entry into the
apparently crowded bug smashing genre
and I would say it's crowded but there's
definitely a genre um there's there's
definitely some things that we would
really like to see fixed and change you
so that it looks great on all Android
devices probably not something that's
too difficult to do possibly you're
going to need to redo some of your
resources but other than that just a
really great game so congratulations mr.
X bug last name X but Mr X by X rock and
that's about all the time we have
actually we've got to get to our next
meeting mm-hmm because we are important
people let important things to do well
least one of us is that would be you
that's because anybody you bet the
leather jacket and I've got the cow hat
so um another another another happy
Friday and thanks for joining us here on
the Friday review that we will see you
next friday at one o'clock p.m. for have
extend for a specific time for the apps
review with rate my red tongue this has
been the games review with Dan Galpin
and Ian new Lewis and we will see you
next week yeah make sure to get on
moderator vote for your own apps vote
for your favorite apps and games and
let's give us a great pipeline of stuff
to look at for next week because you
know this this was actually this was
actually really fun like you were
running dry that was really fun week it
was really fun week I was you know I was
I was a little worried when I first saw
the list but actually you know it turns
out there was lots of really fun stuff
to save it every single one of them and
they were all fun to play so yeah all
right cheers Cheers
you